so I did not watch the Patty penley and  Gordon fight I've seen a lot of the  media and other Fighters tweeting about  it about that it was a worse decision a  robbery I don't know I haven't watched  it I've heard other things as well too  that it wasn't that bad but yeah there's  definitely needs to be something that's  switched up because you have some of  these these same judges making the same  horrible decisions  um I had a fight against Dominic Cruz  that Tony Weeks just made a god-awful  decision it's like they need to be held  accountable for it and um a round by  round score to where the world can see  it would make a big difference as well  as these um judges being held  accountable for their decisions they  need to be doing interviews about it and  being having to tell guys why they  picked whoever they picked because  they're able to just make god-awful  decisions and then not have to be held  accountable for it  [Music]